this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by original grain and you
know what that is because you listen to
this podcast and also you don't live
under a rock and guess what it's your
last chance for father's day it is
around the corner and i got some ideas
for you
uh from our good friends at original
grain check these out
look at this nice understated but classy
they got watches they got glasses they
got all sorts of stuff they got rings
whoop
i had that out already that's why i
didn't put it back right because it's a
got a nice band right there if you go
over there and you use code congrats at
originalgrain.com you'll get 30 off of
the most fashionable watches made from
reclaimed whiskey barrels beer barrels
exotic woods and even taylor guitars
um
if you're a musician so uh you're
guaranteed to find something that fits
your style i've found something to fit
mine look keeping it nice but also
keeping it understated but classy
and um it's great original grain also
plants a tree for every watch they sell
and if you don't like it they'll buy it
back from you but that tree is planted
so there you go um
so they also make awesome wedding rings
see look i got it right there i had it
right there and i put them back there
look at that band that's nice right
um
and uh sunglasses apple watch bands go
over there uh use code congrats at
originalgrain.com congratulation oops
sorry use code congrats at
slash congrats
to get 30 off site wide
uh that's code congrats at
originalgrain.com
slash congrats to get 30 off site wide
make sure you use code congrats for 30
off of
originalgrain.com to support the podcast
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
you know it's another episode dude and i
decided look enough's enough
you forgot to look at the boy in a
flannel though i didn't wear i haven't
been wearing it gets hot in this room
i'm going to be honest with you guys it
gets hot in this room
but i wanted to [ __ ] throw on this
flannel to let you not forget like i
know i've got the the salt and pepper in
the beard but when you throw that
flannel on with the salt and pepper in
the beard it's like whoopsie daisy we
got a whole new look
it's like whoopsie daisy is your boy
from outside of portland it's like
whoopsie daisy you want to [ __ ]
travel an hour to get to seattle
it's like jesus christ it might be rain
you see me you might you'd be like oh we
better go indoors it's going to rain
soon because i'm just [ __ ] keeping it
real nice with the flat when i wear a
flannel all bets are off dude
that's my cape when i wear a flannel
it's just you know i get it in a t-shirt
shore i'm a tall drink of water and
here's the thing man before we even get
into [ __ ]
i uh i'm gonna tell you actually about
this
brand that well let me [ __ ] do this
before we even let me do my dates first
because dude i love you guys and thank
you and grand prairie texas which is
near dallas is on sale uh at pre-sale
it's on pre-sale
uh and if you're here listening to this
wednesday on the patreon
then you are going to get the best seats
there because the code is don't push me
pre-sale don't push me and uh if you
listen to it thursday or friday or
whatever just go get tickets
or hit the pre-sale i don't know how
long the pre-sale's gonna go till but
wichita kansas i'm also doing that
we got the uh don't push me pre-sale on
wednesday and then i'm also gonna be in
atlanta washington dc stockton oakland
all in september in october i'll be in
peoria illinois rockford illinois
raleigh north carolina savannah georgia
and then in november i'll be in denver
colorado cheyenne wyoming boston
massachusetts two shows at the wang
extra paper scoop that up and then in
december i'll be at i just put one on
sale lakeland florida we're going to be
there pre-sale wednesday which is what
you're listening to if you got the
patreon version if not just put the
pre-sale in don't push me
jacksonville florida i'll also be there
that's in december
so yeah
i was
i was i was i was at a co if you're
asking me if i was at a coffee shop yes
i was dude
yes i was at a coffee shop
okay and
i was wearing regular
you know just
kind of regular [ __ ] you know my tattoos
were
on and it's all good
um and i was with my friend and we saw
this super duper cool dude
walk out of the coffee shop
fine
so i'm sitting there
we see a super duper cool dude coming
out of a coffee shop fine he's a cool
dad he's got a kid he's tatted all the
[ __ ] up i like this guy i look at his
clothes i like his clothes i like his
whole deal okay
and then i think i've never seen those
clothes before
and now you know me dude
i mean it's not like i'm over here
at the met gala but your boy knows just
enough fashion to not be considered a
piece of [ __ ] right
like i've got the nice flannel on and it
might be like we might be cl we might be
northwestern right but you're not going
to see me holding an extra head of mine
at the met gala do you know what i'm
talking about
so i see this dude wearing all sorts of
sweats and all sorts of shirts and being
a cool dad all tatted up and i don't
know how old he is 35 to 45 no clue
can't tell sometimes especially because
he had a hat on and sunglasses and a
cool beard
i wanted to be like him
already
so i'm like [ __ ] man look at that and my
buddy says that's cool yeah what out
what it said on the back of his shirt it
said
tracy tracy los angeles so we google it
what the [ __ ] is it we look it up we
look at tracy and then we decide that
the guy who is at the coffee shop was
the owner of tracy los angeles i don't
know why we decided that it's not like
we saw any pictures or anything like
that but we just decided that that was
the owner
okay
months later dude
i'm just scrolling the internet you know
how we do it i'm on instagram just
scrolling
just trying to [ __ ] scroll away my
demons
and all of a sudden
on the inbox i check dude i have a dm
from tracy los angeles
what
now let me just [ __ ] let me start it
off like this dude let me start it off
like the end of it like it's pulp
fiction dude
that's how the story ends dude all right
but they go like this now we're back to
john travolta's alive again okay and we
go we're sitting in the diner with with
[ __ ] uh sam jackson
and guess what dude they dm me hey chris
we're [ __ ] we love your [ __ ] or
something i can't remember what they
said i don't want to misquote them but
something like uh we'd love to send you
some stuff and i go and i say are you
[ __ ] kidding me dude i saw an awesome
tattooed up dude wearing your [ __ ] and i
was like that's some cool clothes like
let me send you this stuff i say my
sizes and boom i got this and boom i got
the [ __ ] flannel and i don't even
mean to shout them out but you know cool
clothes
i don't even mean you know they're not
paying me or anything they just sent me
some [ __ ]
um so it came full circle dude
and then they said we love your style we
want you to wear our clothes and then
i'm like dude am i like that guy
[ __ ] yeah dude i'm a dad i don't have as
many tattoos and maybe i think i
actually still think it is the owner i
don't know but dude i'm [ __ ] so i'm
like that guy if somebody sees me and
they see me in these clothes i'm like
that guy
and they see me with calvin i'm a cool
dad i got the tattoos not as many as
that guy but that's the guy that i'm
like dude and they see tracy
on the back of my [ __ ] that's what i'm
like dude so i'm like that guy god damn
it [ __ ] yeah dude i love it when i'm
like that guy
i love it when i'm like a guy i see that
i like i love that dude i love it when i
see a guy and then i realize that other
people see me like that guy [ __ ] yeah
dude you're not that guy pal
you're not that guy
now my computer's plugged in but here's
the interesting thing it's not charging
so what the [ __ ] does that mean hmm
what does that mean dude does that mean
that it's not plugged into the side of
the wall right there and does that mean
that one fire's about to get [ __ ]
booted is that what that means
[ __ ] yeah dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dude and you heard the
power thing go fluent great dude so many
[ __ ] travesties happening already but
dude that's what i'm saying dude and you
can know me i got my own merch it's at
crystallia.com and we got crazy cool
[ __ ] going on you got tumblers life rips
[ __ ] we got the new life rips with the
puffed out [ __ ] you know and that's the
thing i wear that and when people see me
they go oh [ __ ] i want to be like that
guy
walk into the cult my babies
welcome to the cult dude it's a cult
that's it
so we represent the people we like dude
and i'm a cool dude just sitting outside
the [ __ ] coffee shop man chilling
with calvin i love i love it dude i love
it dude
guess what kevin loves salmon did you
know that dude he loves salmon like
loves it i want salmon
and then i'm eating sam and he says i
could try some
one time i was in a
a car
with
[ __ ] man you know how you remember stuff
but you only kind of like half remember
it
i was in a car with my friend's mom and
his
sister but my friend wasn't there for
some reason they needed to pick me up
from some park
and i had these candies and i was
sitting in the back seat and the sister
was sitting in the front seat she was
younger than me and then the mom was
sitting in the front seat
with the driver's seat obviously
and i was eating the candies
i was such a dick even at [ __ ] up
what i had to be eight
and she turned around and saw me eating
the candies and she said i could have
one and i judged that the mom didn't
hear her say that
and because she said i could have one
and not can i have one i said that's not
how you ask for something he's a dick
even when he's 80 rings true
dude i said that's not how you do it we
went back to one runner sting because we
got [ __ ]
flagged on the two it was too much of
the song hey what do you want dude
so we now we have one dude i haven't get
rid of fix did it i haven't get rid of
one one fire zero
um but yeah dude she said i could have
one i said that's not how you ask for
something and then she dude i was eight
i was such a dick she was probably six
and then and then i think she said it
right or no no then i said i said you're
supposed to say can i have one please
and i think i don't really remember the
rest of it but i think i i like to think
i was a good guy and i gave it to her
because oh [ __ ] i'm an [ __ ] dude wow
you remember the [ __ ] [ __ ] you used
to do as a kid when i was a kid i was in
preschool or i was in k whatever it was
it was mrs pillsbury's is what it was
called it was the place where the
[ __ ] lady squeezed my cheeks too hard
once because i went down the slide wrong
all good
she squeezed my cheeks too hard if i
ever become a serial killer that's the
thing i'm gonna go that's the defense
i'm gonna go with
well did you know that the defendant
had his squeeze has his cheeks squeezed
too hard when he was at mrs pillsbury's
no
oh no i'm some or the order order order
um
she squeezed my cheeks real hard i
didn't tell my mom two years later and
she said you should have told it you
should have told us that i didn't though
and it's fine she squeezed my cheeks and
i'm fine about it but um
it hurt and it scared me but it's fine
i'm fine about it and um
she's a cheek squeezer and so she uh she
did that and then in that same place
wherever the school was it had like a
kitchen and [ __ ] how is it a school but
anyway it had a kitchen
and was it just a house was i just at
someone's house what the [ __ ] is mrs
pillsbury's
it was in new jersey i don't know it was
also the 80s so it was completely it
literally could have been like some
[ __ ] somebody's house now they would
never do that they would never have
school at somebody's house but um i went
there and they i was eating snack time
and somebody was eating wafers and she
was eating the waiver so little i talked
about this before my podcast she was
eating away for so little and i and i
was it was great and dude i was like a
young larry david i was like [ __ ]
nine just just in my own career
enthusiasm
and uh and i was looking at her and i
finally couldn't take it i said how come
you're eating such small bites and she
said because it lasts longer that way oh
dude and i got angry because i think
yeah but don't you want more in your
mouth you want more satisfaction all at
once rather than [ __ ] spanned out
for too long also it gets old dude i
want the see this is why i'm an addict
and she's not and she's got a [ __ ]
beautiful life and a family and
everything and there's never been any
sort of and never been done and now
because she takes small bites of her way
for his [ __ ] yeah dude i would take that
whole wafer and just
run around like a tree trimmer just [ __ ]
it dude all of it i want all the flavor
in my mouth at once swallow and then
move the [ __ ] on dude
that's how i eat that's how i eat i'm
not as bad as mike linocchi the guy who
the guy the the comedian michael noche
which i hang with a lot he [ __ ] eats
[ __ ] and he's like we got to finish this
food to move on to the dessert we
finished the dessert we got to move on
to the next thing i'm not like that i
enjoy it but i do it quickly dude but
i'll eat that [ __ ] like a tree trimmer
or a [ __ ] log trim or whatever
and she was just taking her sweet time
it's like what are we doing dude it's
like it's like it's like i was talking
to my uncle the other day about uh uh
about uh western medicine versus eastern
medicine and he was like well you know
western medicine's good but also if you
go to the [ __ ] eastern like these if
you have a bruise in asia and you go to
a doctor they like america they'll just
like ice the bruise and like just local
write locally around the bruise or just
try to get the bruise as small as it can
but in the in in the east though if
you're in asia they'll try to spread the
bruise out so there's less pain all over
your body and i say yeah i don't know
don't you think that western medicine
though it's like there's science and
stuff involved and he said yeah but
who's done medicine longer and then that
was when i was just like okay well i
don't i don't even want to you know
i don't even want to have that okay
sure if you're that you know what i mean
if you're that if you're that
i'm never that hell bent on any argument
unless it's like literally about the
dumbest [ __ ] and this is was a little
bit too medical for me to really
and so that's what she was doing she was
spreading the bruise out for you know
and i'm just like a western that's what
she was doing with the with the wafer
just trying to make it last longer
throughout her whole body and me i'm
more of a [ __ ] western medicine type
dude you know
i'm the guy who goes in that just eats
the [ __ ] wafers all at once and just
has a flavor explosion in his mouth
um
that is what i want though dude it's
crazy it's crazy
it's crazy how much i
i do that i think about my ticket sales
i look at how many tickets i sold and
i'm like how do i get more how do i
[ __ ] sell 10 more tickets how do i
sell 30 more tickets how do i sell you
know what i mean and then once i can add
another show like i [ __ ] added in the
boston i'm just like [ __ ] yeah dude off
to the races dude and i just think about
like i wanted oh [ __ ] dude i gotta catch
ah [ __ ] man gotta catch me i gotta
realize i got a great life see
i have a great life i've got a beautiful
son a beautiful beautiful girl whom i
love very much
we hold each other we talk
me and kristen we talk we have good
times we laugh
you know we make fun of each other in
beautiful ways we get in very minimal
arguments
right
and
you know
we do kisses we do all sorts of stuff
but it's you know and then my son
it's beautiful he comes up to me and he
you know i put pomade in his hair the
other day for the first time i put his
hair back like he was a [ __ ] ceo it's
awesome dude i put his hair back and he
didn't was like no no no no and i kept
doing it i kept doing it until he was
finally fine with it i looked in the
mirror and he looked like a ceo
he's boss baby he looked like a ceo so
i'm like it looks like when he talks
alec baldwin's voice is going to come
out
so
i saw dr death by the way
i saw that show from joshua joshua
jackson is in it
dude there's definitely two levels of
acting there's three levels of acting
and that's it there's bad acting there's
fine acting and then there's [ __ ]
crazy good acting
three levels bad
fine crazy good
and like i watched this [ __ ] dr death
show and joshua jackson is fine and i no
hate dude he's a handsome dude he was in
dawson's creek and you know
i know my ex-girlfriend thinks he's very
sexy and that's fine dude and he was in
that show the affair apparently the show
the affair was good my ex-girlfriend
liked it a lot
fine dude she liked it a lot said he was
sexy fine doesn't really bother me
because i find that he is kind of
whatever it's not up to me she likes who
she likes and she said that when we were
dating and that's whatever it's fine and
she likes joshua jackson she thinks he's
sexy and that's fine she also said the
other guy in the affair was very sexy
and that's fine so now i'm like well
maybe she just likes affairs which
doesn't make much sense why she got so
mad at me when i had one now oops right
now oops but also maybe that's why she
thinks i'm sexy right because i was a
bad boy
reformed but bad boy
and um
you know
she she liked um
joshua jackson in that and so i took a
peek at the doctor death dude took a
peek at the doctor death
and i did it because i saw it on a
billboard and it was on peacock and i
like peacock so sue me i like peacock
peacock hbo max those are the two hot
shits right now dude all right
i like peacock i didn't know peacock
peacock there's peacock and there's nbc
i had no idea
there's a nbc app and peacock what's the
difference i don't know but on peacock
they all say [ __ ] stuff a lot like
doctor that they were saying [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and they had like you know
joshua jackson's a fine actor
now sorry but christian slater's a bad
actor he shows up and he's talking and
he's just
he's not good
and there's some good acting there's
some bad acting him but then alec
baldwin shows up
and there's a guy who's crazy good dude
and he's crazy good in doctor death
and it's a fun watch but this is about
this christopher dunch dude that was
just a lunatic man
christopher dunch and yes i i heard the
podcast dr death and i've seen the show
doctor death and i even saw the [ __ ]
documentary mini series that they did on
nbc which they left out a lot of that
[ __ ] i didn't know he was toting a gun
around and [ __ ] the guy was but by the
way if you're a surgeon and you're not
doing coke you're not at that [ __ ]
level where you're operating where you
should be if you're a true surgeon you
got to do
coke when you're on your day off
you have to do
you got to be like scarface sitting
there just looking around thinking about
an empire dude you
and let me tell you something
nobody does more coke than a [ __ ]
surgeon and i and i won't hear anything
other than that
i won't hear anything other than that
all doctors they do mountains of coke
dude especially young ones and if you're
in your if you're dude if you're it
peaks it's like a young doctor young hot
shot doctor you're getting [ __ ]
you're you know 30 35 year old wow dude
lots of coke you get to do 40 years old
lots of coke and then you have a family
right you do a little bit less coast but
you still do it and then it becomes like
you know 45 50s every night and then you
have everything and then 60 and then you
go down but you do mountains of coke if
you put on a lab coat
mountains of coke
and uh maybe not if you're like a
pediatrician but like wow that would be
hilarious so what we got you want
lollipops what you got you want a
lollipop
[Music]
look you cringe at the pump don't you
the gas prices are high you get an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant you get it that's what
happened inflation it's hitting us all
where it hurts and let me tell you
something
it really hurts right
it hurts it's like an arrow to the chest
that's why i started using upside
okay upside is an incredible it's this
cool app it's incredible for anyone who
buys gas groceries or dines out so
basically anyone okay with every
purchase
i am earning cash
back thanks to upside you can open the
app and see places around you offering
cashback is very great i was recently a
little bit hungry you know how i get i
get hungry sometimes walking around
doing my thing i opened up the app okay
i see this place that i like is part of
upside
cafe gratitude i like this place i like
the food there i went there i got a
smoothie there and boom there's cash in
my account that i could cash out to my
bank or add to amazon so it's like
okay they figured it out upside figured
out life it's the best app
to get started download the free upside
app in the app store or google play use
my promo code delea and get five dollars
or more cash back on your first purchase
of ten dollars or more so use the code
delea and that's what you get that's
free money okay
next claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with your normal
credit or debit card and get paid dude
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or e-gift card or for
amazon and uh and other brands um
yeah i mean upside users are earning
more than a million dollars every week
so you know you do the math download the
free upside app and use promo code dalia
to get five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
ten dollars or more so go get it get
upside crazy
crazy
crazy
so um
yeah this guy is uh christopher dunch is
a spinal surgeon
that
uh came up to the ranks in school and
was this hot shot doctor but it was all
style and [ __ ] i guess and oh just ego
imagine the ego you have to have as a
surgeon though for real
what do you do i make sure people
[ __ ] live i save lives a lot a lot a
lot of uh
surges probably think they're a little
bit jesus christ you know
but this guy thought he was god man and
he would go in and he would [ __ ] he
would convince people to get surgeries
even if they didn't need to and then he
would just paralyze them it was the war
and some people died the weirdest serial
killer ever if you're this is the thing
about christopher dunch why he's a
[ __ ] cold-hearted [ __ ] because dude
if you're gonna serial killer if you're
gonna be a serial killer go out there
get all the [ __ ]
be israel keys set up kill kits put them
around the country leave them there for
years and then when you vacation with
the family find people where the kill
kits are get the ski mask get the gloves
to zip ties and go on a killing spree
and then go home
be on the lamb
you're a [ __ ] ass if you use an
anesthetic
this is why i don't have respect for
this [ __ ] yeah he's a serial
killer but he did it like getting a
degree and [ __ ] dude i don't want my
sewer killers having degrees i want my
serial killers to be transients
i want my serial killers to be like
outside of a gas station looking for
something and when you ask them what's
up they say
[Music]
i want them to drive a [ __ ] old
chevelle or a station wagon even worse a
buick
i don't want them rolling around a bmw's
i don't give a [ __ ] dude oh ted bundy oh
yeah but he was a professional and he
was handsome and charismatic [ __ ] out of
here dude charles manson all day long
and let me tell you the other thing
charles mason never actually killed
anyone he just convinced people to kill
people so that's some other bit [ __ ]
john wayne gacy
richard ramirez
but i don't want to be one of those
[ __ ]
idiots like it drives me nuts when
[ __ ] chicks are like oh but they're
so sexy and it's like dude really stare
a serial killer in the eyes alone you
won't you won't you won't jeffrey dahmer
there you go dude i want weirdos
i don't want these [ __ ]
buttoned up like well let's see let's
take a look at you okay you need surgery
and then put them under and then
dead kind of bitch-ass [ __ ] is that what
is this dr giggles
i used to be so scared of that [ __ ]
movie dr giggles man
god that guy was so scary in that
[ __ ] show in that movie they used to
play on hbo when i was a kid
oh man there was one time where he went
under the sheets and took a scalpel and
[ __ ] stabbed it in into a girl's like
well i now now that i think about it it
was her [ __ ] but in my head as a kid i
was like oh why is he doing that to her
belly button and it's like okay well all
right
we get it and you wonder why i'm the
kind of guy that says that's not how you
ask
is it when i'm [ __ ] eight years old
or when i'm pissed off at a girl taking
little bites like little larry david
that's what i'm saying dude
ah
it is what it is
it's hard not to be pushed right
this amber heard uh johnny depp thing is
insane huh can we like is it done now it
was done and then everyone's still
i don't even know what to say about it
dude i [ __ ] put out a tick tock about
uh about it uh but i you know it was
something that was like
oh i said on my show months ago and now
everyone [ __ ] goes nuts you know
because like i said it and [ __ ]
everyone's mad that i said it do it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] everyone you know
try to [ __ ]
just
try to hold my son and [ __ ] be with
my family
oh dude how about the fact that
let me every now like
hollywood is
it's still kicking it's like you know
what it's like hollywood's like that
[ __ ] they've never seen faces of
death where they bash that monkey's
brain in and eat it and the monkey just
like pop and the people are pop pop the
white people are just pop pop and the
monkey's like
pop
and then
pop and then
finally and then they
and then they
um
that's hollywood dude
everyone just [ __ ] hollywood just
that monkey
and it's still act and it's just at that
last blow dude
and that last blow right there is
[ __ ] them re-releasing morbius how'd
they do it dude
how'd you do it hollywood
how'd you tko yourself
the will smith thing happened
right
pimp slapped the comedian for saying
something
how the [ __ ]
what's up with this [ __ ] release of
morbius it's awful dude morbius was a
bad this is the thing dude people don't
want to go see movies as jokes i've said
this since snakes on a plane everyone
thought snakes on the plane was gonna be
[ __ ]
hollywood was like oh it's basic enough
oh it's a joke or people think it's
funny or everyone's gonna go see it it
came out what did it do it did fine
thank god because of sam jackson
it didn't [ __ ] go gangbusters like
they thought it was going to right
and now because there's memes of jared
leto they re-release morbius
it made 40 grand
morbius came out it came and got down
payment for a house
movie is re-released it just was unr it
just was ticking from the [ __ ]
you could buy four boats with the money
they made
you could throw a nice kind of party for
the money amanda
they thought memes were gonna save
morbius dude you thought
memes were gonna save it memes destroyed
it
some [ __ ] hot shot exec you know
dude nah get out of here with that you
know
nah
they need me dude they need me they need
to hire me as my you know what my
[ __ ] position is
that's my position that's what they call
it we need to get the [ __ ] uh in here
i come in and whenever they say
something stupid
and i walk up to them and i do this to
their chest until they keep walking
backwards out of the door and then i
close it
and i ask them to not wd40 the door
i ask them to make the door squeakier so
it's more disrespectful
because i'm here for the company to
understand universal to understand pair
my mount
but i just thought if we ah
because of the meme
because of the meme power because i uh
and jared leto has proven to be ah
[Music]
now when are we making top gun three
morbius dude
michael morbius
should have known once it like changed
his name dude you know like [ __ ] it i
want there should be a movie about how
cool would this be dude how [ __ ]
awesome would this movie be
and this and i've thought about this so
much and i wanted to make this movie so
badly and i'll never make this movie but
i want to and you'll steal this idea
somebody will steal this idea no no they
actually they won't because they won't
do it the way i want to do it this is
the best movie this is one of the best
[ __ ] movie ideas i ever had and i've
had it for like 20 [ __ ] years okay
this guy
is [ __ ]
being himself and it's like takes place
over two [ __ ] three weeks and [ __ ]
and you notice that he's [ __ ] cool
but he's trying to keep it together and
then you don't realize what's going on
you think maybe it's a drug problem or
what it is and then at the end you don't
even realize it and the movie ends and
then a week later you realize oh
that movie was about superman trying to
not be superman dude
yeah dude for real that movie would be
so ill if a director like a christopher
nolan type dude made it direct made a
movie and it would use this star power
to just make this [ __ ] movie but dude
was just hanging out for three weeks
like dating and also going to work and
[ __ ] he worked at maybe a newspaper part
but they didn't call him clark kent you
never even heard his name and then at
the end [ __ ] the movie ends and the
movie leaves theaters and was like we
didn't really understand it and then
christopher nolan does a review does an
interview about the movie and says well
you know that movie was about superman
trying to not be superman for three
weeks
hollywood dude are you serious that [ __ ]
would go gangbusters man i'm serious i
would make such good movies
i don't know
i don't know i got a [ __ ] you know i
got a new place where i go and i go eat
food
and it's nice to get a turkey club it's
amazing they finally put enough cheese
in it thank god
they finally put enough cheese in
[ __ ] club sandwiches man
i'm not going to tell you where it is
because like i want to keep going and i
go and i go i [ __ ] i go to park and
there's never enough parking and
everyone's always double parked and it's
so illegal but it's whatever dude and
sometimes i can't even get out of my car
because another car is parked illegally
right outside of me and it's like okay
i'll just wait some days i just wait but
some days i'm pissed off and i get i
start doing stuff like
doesn't help anything
and uh i find a spot i get there a lady
gets in her car she sits down
in her car it's taking a bit
so you know me dude
i roll up
i'm not the guy who doesn't say anything
but i realize how sometimes i come
across right
so i roll down the window and i say hey
are you leaving and she says yeah but
give me f uh she says yeah but i'm
looking up for directions on where to go
on my phone give me five minutes
[Music]
takes
twenty-six we don't you know i mean
click the goddamn thing that somebody
sent you or or just [ __ ] google it
and then click that doesn't take five
minutes five minutes now you're pushing
and now you're doing the thing they say
it takes people longer to get out of the
parking sp they did a study and it was
like it takes longer for people to get
out of the parking spaces if they know
you're waiting for them and i'm just
like humanity is doomed
you i mean that's like [ __ ] six
goddamn uh beaches of normandy to me
that's so horrible
that that statistic is so horrible it's
worth six beaches of normandies
you know what i'm talking about what
why have i been hurrying up i've been
hurrying up dude
and then the guy and the [ __ ]
postmates nobody can do their goddamn
job dude
i need to relax though you know because
here's the thing i want to be
i want to be uh you know
i think sometimes i let [ __ ] life and
like the things the hustle and bustle
you know get to me and i either get
depressed or angry
or whatever
and it's very easy to get caught up in
uh
the the day-to-day of it right like i
gotta do this podcast and i gotta do
lifeline then i gotta do a king in this
thing in the wing or whatever it is you
know
i gotta think about you know i gotta
think about my tour i gotta [ __ ] put
these dates on tour i gotta post this
then or then and it's very easy to get
caught up and not realize
i'm a human being we're all human beings
i want what's best for everybody
and i do need to check myself sometimes
if i'm being honest
and uh
you know that being said the way the guy
delivered the postmates earlier today
was just a [ __ ] travesty and it was
uncalled for he he it was so
he dude bring it to the
we've had so many [ __ ] issues with
post to bring it to the [ __ ] my
address is what my address is right
bring it there but then the guys today
it was
oh
it says he's arriving in ikea thank god
by the way so i could at least look out
for the car
i see a guy in ikea literally just
[ __ ]
a block down just doing this with this
kia right here this is the car
and then reversing all the way back to
me
reversing on the street all the way back
to me in the kia
park's
too far away keep reversing all the way
to me right but he didn't he stopped
parked too far away and then walked up
to me
holding the bags and said hey sorry it
said the other house and i said well
what did the address say told me the
address and then pointed to the curb
right next to me because i was right
outside my house and he said yeah but
look and showed me
something
and the only reason why i say he showed
me something and i don't describe it is
because it didn't matter because the
[ __ ] thing what he showed me was what
he thought my house was on the [ __ ]
shaded in region because of the location
dude but the address is right there dude
i told you about the one time where the
dude came up and he was like sorry your
address the addresses on your street go
up and then down and then up again and i
was like okay i guess i'm just not gonna
win against postmates they don't go up
and then down and then up again anywhere
on the planet
one two three four you [ __ ] calvin
one two three and eighteen four two and
one
no dude
you're a grown-ass 27 year old adult
so
anyway it took her [ __ ] five minutes
to leave the parking lot and got i got
pissed off and i [ __ ] went i left i
left and i went to
i got another another spot here dude i
want to talk about these guys again
these guys are just these shawnee and
bria
on uh
on
tiktok there's a video i put out it kind
of went viral but it was a clip from a
podcast about the funniest clip i've
ever seen on the internet
and you can google it but it's uh bro
it's this guy was like what the [ __ ]
up with the lights chocolate croissants
i think we called it chocolate croissant
i don't know if we did call the episode
that but dude this is an update and i
saw two seconds of it i wanted to save
it
i know you're sensitive but you got to
put your [ __ ] away there we go here
tonight yeah
50 bucks this is not a free hotel
yeah where's normandy never came up
i love this guy she spilled it
[Laughter]
dude why do i love this guy so much no i
told you to do it before you even
[ __ ] did it and i dude so
just just done i love this guy see what
did i tell her oh you didn't no i told
you before you even [ __ ] did it but
you did it
dude oh see i told you did the tired the
exasperated just how [ __ ] cocksure he
is about the past is what i love he
knows about the past better than
it's like
it's like he's a psychic no that's what
it is he knows about the future like
it's the past and then tells you about
it after it happens yes i figured out
how to say the sentence dude he knows
about the future and tells you about it
after it happens
like he's pissed off he didn't call it
yes he said it again in a good way
dude it's amazing this guy's amazing i
do this [ __ ] all the time and i love it
and krista gets mad at me yes dude i
deserve it
but we kiss him we cuddle sometimes too
so it's all about balancing
what i tell her
no i told you before i even [ __ ] did
it but you did it wow that
is and then he goes
and then he goes
[ __ ] by himself dude
unbelievable dude this guy is on this
guy is my [ __ ] marvel superhero i
want to play it again
yeah where's normandy never came up
see what did i tell her oh you didn't no
i told you before you even [ __ ] did
it but you did it
[ __ ]
your head what did you that's a threat
i'm gonna tell my dad on you tell him
i'll tell him what you're doing what am
i doing getting high at noon
stay what stay until when
wednesday wednesday
she's staying till
oh my god cracked her [ __ ]
toe and said knuckle
unreal dude
i better start drinking then
can i have this sure
you put it in the garbage when you're
done
why are you throwing it's so good that's
what that second [ __ ] away
staying here tonight yeah
50 bucks this is not a free hotel right
here right here this is my favorite dude
yeah where's normandy he never came up
see what did i tell her oh you didn't no
i told you before you even [ __ ] did
it but you did it
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
no i [ __ ] told you before you even
did it and you did it dude why is this
guy so funny
shaunie and bread dude
oh [ __ ] we love them
what the [ __ ] up with the lights
[ __ ] up with the lights i gotta take i
gotta take a piss i'll be right back
oh god
we were at uh i went i went to the
bathroom guys thanks very much for uh
keeping me
let me let me do that dude i went i
thought i had to go number one and we'll
just leave it at that um but i didn't
think i had to go number one and i did
go number one but i also we'll just
leave it at that um
i'll just leave it at that right
um
yeah i wanted to actually i got this
from my discord on my patreon which is
great and amy kenyon sent it and uh i
did not i heard i overheard and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that and i was
like i want to play that a little love
tap on the 10 pin chris by just feeding
it out to that 4-5 board down lane and
look at this pin action
[Laughter]
dude got a finger in his butt
absolutely [ __ ] came so hard
you know i come doctor you know doc if i
if i see the last pin fall gingerly i
bust a nut
we have no medication look at this nice
break a little love tap on the 10 pin
chris vi just feeding it out to that 4 5
board down lane and look at this pin
action
[Laughter]
dude how could you do that dude he's
probably one of those dudes that has no
idea either just like some 55 year old
white guy that just is like what do you
mean oh no i didn't even think of that
like dude you sounded like you were
busting your guts
oh
all right check out that break the guy
needs a break oh look at that beautiful
break there we go beautiful breaking
nine nights off nine pins oh and
announcement teetering and it would go
oh
god
just [ __ ] that was a beautiful shot
all over oh
god oh the pin falls all over oh look at
it dribble
dribble down your chin
um
that's unbelievable that he did that
uh
no we did we went out and we [ __ ] got
a nice [ __ ]
dinner dude
you ever think about that you ever go
out and get a nice dinner dude we went
to go do a show i was with kristen and
another couple [ __ ] double dating it
up you know
you know double dang it you know and
this [ __ ] they wanted to come out do
a show we [ __ ] get an early show and
we were saying we're going to leave it
by [ __ ] 7 30 of course we left by a
cause kristen and it's all good dude and
we got to the [ __ ] laugh factory and
i [ __ ] absolutely
don't know what i mean
actually the crowd wasn't even that
great i thought i did only okay
he's got to stay humble he's got to stay
honest
and uh i thought i did okay i said it
was okay and they were like no it was
great and so i was like okay and they're
like you want to go eat and i was like
yeah okay sure and i was like do where
do you want to go and they were like
let's go to a [ __ ] nice sit-down
place and i was like all right i like
diners but okay okay
all right i like dinosaurs but okay i
acquiesce and everyone was like well
maybe we should go here there and then
finally krista made the executive
decision let's go to isabel and i was
like okay that's a [ __ ] that's a very
sit-down place right
it's a very big place that's very
beautiful
and it's very nice we're really nice
cars outside so we take the [ __ ]
throat mobile we drive over there it's
got four seats even though two are
buckets and we go there and i don't want
the [ __ ] guy to crash my car so i say
can i park it in the lot and he says
actually i have to and it's like
whenever somebody does that with the
valet you're like yeah but no you don't
right because that's just a rule that we
made up
and nobody also is gonna what what's
gonna happen
can i par can i pull it in actually we
have to
for what what's gonna happen the [ __ ]
valet police are gonna come out
and throw you in [ __ ] jail
when you wanna come back and get your
husband here's your ticket to the
[ __ ] wife
when the guy gets thrown in jail
[Laughter]
hey i'm in here i'm in ballet jail
um
so racist i gave him a mexican accent
but you know what i mean and um hey when
can when my wife can get me does she
actually need the actual ticket or do
you guys have an app or what um
and uh
so i say can i do and he's like now and
i was like well okay the car's really
low and he said it's okay i'll park it
out here for the vip i was like oh is it
double the price and he was like yeah i
was like
welcome to suckerville dude so i gave it
to him and i'm all good and we went to
isabel we had a good time and you know
everyone's drinking but me right because
i don't drink
and uh strip clubs became a topic and i
was like oh no i'm listening
you know what i mean we were talking
everything was good but by the way
everything was good because i was like
i had a lot of sleep that night
uh the night before drank some nice
coffees head of events and then
everything was great dude right i
probably had three five answers in my
life by the way because i know in the
comments people are like well it's
probably all the drugs that's [ __ ]
yolk did i take drugs okay i take like
[ __ ] two xanax a month and three
vivants ever
all right
so we're talking and we're having good
conversation but then the conversation
levels up and we start talking about
strip clubs and now i'm like i'm
interested i used to go to a strip clubs
a lot i used to go all the time i used
to go in my 20s i used to run that [ __ ]
i used to go there and make friends dude
it was the beginning of my addiction and
i was you know it was like in the
beginning of [ __ ] um a mob movie when
it was like and that was when i realized
i was one of the guys
right that was me in my early 20s when i
walked into this strip club
and that was when i realized things i
was actually gonna become a maid man hey
honey wanna dance splirt
and there's johnny there's johnny nine
fingers we don't even know how he lost
his other finger hey honey wanna dance
sure splurt ka-ching
right
when you did you know you can go so deep
in the valley that it's basically mexico
hey honey want to dance splurt zip
ching
as out of the order i was out of order
but um
anyway uh i would go there
and uh
my god what the [ __ ]
what a funny [ __ ] time in my life
uh and so i hadn't been i haven't been
to the strip club i don't know when the
last time i went to the strip club was i
i don't even know uh
i don't know when the last time was
maybe on a not even on a bachelor party
i don't know it's been [ __ ] so long
but
kristen was there and the other couple
was there and the other couple was
talking about how they go to us they
went to a strip club and how it was fun
and then chris was like we should go and
i was like
really and she was like yeah and i was
like man it's been so long but also i'm
listening right
but also maybe we shouldn't go
but also i'm less than right so i'm like
hmm so i'm like oh that's very
interesting like
we probably shouldn't go but also hmm
right
and uh
so okay so we end up going
one time i was at the strip club when i
was in my [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was probably in my ear well i was
probably like twenty
eight no it was probably earlier than
that actually 25 or something
and i was getting a day some i was just
hanging out with my buddy
and he was uh he wanted to go to the
strip club and we went to the strip club
and he was like he wanted to get a dance
from a specific girl and i was just
chilling i didn't want to i was just
chilling and then he was like off
getting a dance with her for like way
too long and this girl kept coming up
he's like sure you want to dance i was
like nah i'm good it's like you sure you
don't want to dance like nah i'm good
it's like sure you don't want it that's
like now i'm good and he was there for
so long and she's like you sure don't
want to dance i'm like all right honey
you wore me out you wore me out let's go
you know what i mean let's just go let's
just go back there i've got a wad let's
just go and we went and she did the lap
dance and she asked me if i wanted
another song and i said yes and then she
asked me if i wanted another song and
then i said yes and then i said that's
probably it and then she [ __ ] hugged
me and she hugged me for too long i
didn't really know what was going on and
then i started bouncing and i realized
it was actually her that's bouncing
because she was
crying on my shoulder
and i said
nothing for a while
and then she said
take me away from here
ah
dude she said
take me away from here and she was
keeping my shoulder wet
swat
dude unreal
and i go do you want to know what oh
you're probably like waiting with baited
breath but chris what did you do and say
here's what i did
here's what i did [ __ ] 26 year old me
i go like this
and did a phantom hug didn't even
oh oh
literally that's what i did
waited for a little bit
left peter
felt bad but what am i going to do you
know take away from you taking my house
she [ __ ] robs me or her [ __ ] dudes
comment [ __ ] they all take my money
and [ __ ] me in the ass
just rubbing up against the pillow no i
get it no i get it
you know
i see
you're trying to take advantage of guys
with hearts
all right i get it i get it i get it
so um anyway that happened and so that
was one of the times i'll never forget
it
i'll never forget that i will never
forget that dude and so went to that
same strip club
the body shop on sunset we took it we
took the throat mobile got out
went in and i forgot the place caught
fire and then they had to rebuild it i
haven't been there in so long and they
re they rebuilt it i walked in and it
was like walking into a [ __ ] like it
was like i fell asleep and dreamt the
place that's what it was because it was
kind of the same but also a little bit
different it was a little bright i went
in there
and the girls ran away immediately and i
was telling them dude i was telling them
beforehand i was telling the guy in the
in the couple's relationship that we
were in the that we were with i was like
bro you know when i went to the strip
club i would go because i would i would
try to get extra nice with it right like
that's where i would go to try and learn
how to hit on like chicks i would go to
the strip club and i knew they would
come up to me and that's when i would
learn how to get super nice with it
right like i talked to him and i would
be like ooh i could probably have sex
with these ladies and that's how i
learned to get super nice with it okay
and i was telling them
and then the ladies
me and the the you know kristen and her
friend and then
the other dude the ladies when it went
away and it was just being the other
dude and he looked at me and said you
know it would be i don't know where the
girls are but it would be kind of cool
to see if you still were really nice
with it
[Laughter]
but i didn't feel like being nice with
it you know i was just chilling and you
know i don't
you know it's like
and of course another [ __ ] stripper
came up to me and she was like when the
ladies come back do you want us to give
them a dance and i was just like i don't
know if they're gonna want that but
maybe you just let me know i'm rosanna
and i was like do you know a girl cried
here i never mind i took a okay thank
you
and so we went and it was really just it
didn't i don't know if it was because i
was [ __ ] running out of vivants or
what but it wasn't popping man
it wasn't popping
it wasn't that good you know yeah we saw
some titties we saw also there's always
that couple in the strip club where
you're like
who are they and how do they get
together like we saw a dude that looked
like celo and a woman that was looked
like a [ __ ] like the highest real
estate agent in los angeles and it was
like how did they get together dude and
the dude was so bossed up he wasn't even
looking at the thing he was just like
throwing money on the thing like this
just like throwing money at the
disrespectful but also stripping is just
the whole thing so disrespectful
and then chris was like want to go and
i'm like yeah and so we went and i you
know
i didn't activate my niceness but but we
left and then um
kristen reminded me of a time where we
were taught we were watching uh when we
first started dating we were watching
this [ __ ] documentary called when
porn ends
which just sounds like something that
i really want to watch you know so i
turn it on and when we turn it on man
porn stars and comics they
absolutely
uh
run in the same circles you know like
there were so there were always porn
stars at every show and there still are
it's just crazy i don't know why but and
then some of them want to like get on
stage and do shows with like sam tripoli
or some [ __ ] it's like hilarious
and so i you know i hung out with a lot
of porn stars and so
uh we watched this thing and kristen was
like let's watch it and i realized now
that she wanted
she i don't know if she wanted to watch
it or not but you know she was intrigued
and
and so she's like let's watch this okay
but like i got to be honest with you
guys with you with you babe like there
might be women in this
pl this documentary that i've hung out
with and she was like it's okay so tell
me you know it's like all right fine
and so we start the documentary and it's
like talking heads and [ __ ] you know and
this one porn star and she's like so
when i started porn and then after this
and then another one comes down oh i
started always saying oh i know her we
hung out and she's like really and i'm
like yeah another talking head and i was
like oh i i we hung out too and she was
like what and i was like yeah oh her two
and we got the boy dude there were five
and i was like oh damn i know [ __ ]
her too i was even like myself shocked
she looks over at me doing it and she is
[ __ ] smiling but just tears in her
eyes
and i was like oh no and she's like it's
fine i just didn't know it was going to
be this many
dude it was it was horrendous
and i turned it off and we hugged dude
and i felt bad
my addiction affects people
but yeah dude there were so many there
were so many
oh
man dude oh god
calvin if you're listening when you grow
up i'm sorry you know
well everyone that's it for youtube if
you want to catch the rest of the
episode the uncut episode you gotta hit
our patreon patreon.com crystalia we've
got extra uh um
all the episodes are longer on the on
the patreon thing on the patreon uh
thing so go over there and do that and
then also there's every month there's a
new patreon go go binge go binge go
watch the old one sign up for our
patreon patreon.com and watch the old
patreon exclusive episodes it's like
four of 14 of them so go over there and
do it like it's breaking bad binge em
dude sign up today
[Music]
okay let's do it let's start it going